Faith seems to play a role in expanding imagination, but what, how, what, how do you think this works, do you think more of it can be done? And how do you, how do you suggest
that we get people to practically understand what is at stake and how we can do something about it?
I, probably the best thing I've learned the last ten years about faith
comes from First Thessalonians in the, in
the New Testament, where Paul's writing a letter and
he's writing the letter to the Thessalonians and he's saying that, that when Silvanus, Timothy,
and I came to you
we had power,
we had the Holy Spirit,
and we had true conviction.
And what I learned from that is the best thing I've learned in ten years about faith
and, and growing
is where I,
when I go to a difficult place or I'm in a difficult situation, I take a prayer partner with me.
This is a practical thing
and it's not
it's, it's something that Jesus did, Paul did.
They were very seldom ever alone.
The only time they were alone when they were with God.
But they always took people with them
and Paul says, you know,
do this,
when two or more are gathered together I'm there,
if you do this you have power. And I can't tell you how many times I've been to North
Korea,
the Congo,
when you meet, and you go to difficult places and you see people dying and
the power of two or more together and
what happens is every morning we get up if we're on a trip and we,
we would pray before the day would start and then when we go, if I'm meeting with somebody
that's really poor, a mother or something, or I'm meeting with the prime minister,
my friend, who is with me, I just introduce him as an agriculture specialist, which he was,
but he's praying.
He doesn't tell
the person he's praying.
He prays.
I can't tell you
how many times
I've seen that conversation turn around,
where we leave the country and
not because we have a sparkling personalities.
It's because, you know, you people are different, this is really, this is
some of the best conversations I ever had. It's because
of what I learned from Paul that when you take a prayer partner you have support. You're stronger.
You're, you have the power with you
and it's,
it really works. I mean it's the most interesting thing that I've learned the last ten. It's so simple that
there's so many lessons that we can learn
from the,
from the scriptures but we, we bypass it because they're too simple
they, they don't work.
And I find
and when I face a difficult situation
like a fast
if I ask other people, if I get people to pray with me,
I don't have to announce it to the world.
The power is there. Is it okay if I ask just a quick follow-up question? What if people don't see their fast as necessary? How do you, how do you get either faith or something else to help people to see that something's going on? Well,
you know what, I do the things in front of me. I don't try to save everybody.
I try to,
you know, I just go
and I do and I pray and
I try to be led by the Lord, not every issue,
I can't, you know, I, I can't find an answer to every issue in the scriptures. I mean, you know,
the far right
they loved to,
the moral majority, they used to love to do a voting record
on congressmen.
And they, they always had ten votes every year
and this is the far
evangelical right and
out of ten votes I always maybe got three right,
so therefore
because I only vote thirty percent of the time,
I can't be a Christian.
But I'm looking at some of their issues, you know, one of the issues was
corporation franchise tax
and I'm thinking
I'm looking in the scriptures for what Jesus says about the corporation franchise,
I can find it
and so that,
that gets back to
one of the issues you said that,
you know, you can use religion in such a way that it's so odious
that it turns people off of God
and that those, those are some of the things that are being done
in American politics
and a lot of other places.